see me draw a few pictures of your
neural network in this video we'll talk
about exactly what those pictures means
in other words actly what those little
neural networks have been drawing on
represent and we'll starts were focusing
on the case of neural networks with
what's called a single hidden layer she
is a picture of a neural net let's give
different parts of these pictures some
names we have the input features x1 x2
x3 Stata vertically and this is called
the input layer of the neural network so
maybe not surprisingly this contains the
inputs to the neural network then
there's another layer of circles and
this is called a hidden layer of the
neural network I'll come back in a
second to say what the word hidden means
but the final layer here is formed by in
this case just one note and this single
note layer is called the output layer
and it's responsible for generating the
predicted value Y hat in a neural
network the you train with supervised
learning the training set contains
values of the inputs X as well as the
target outputs Y so the term hidden
layer refers to the fact that in the
training set the true values for these
nodes in the middle are not observed
that is you don't see what they should
be in the training set you see what the
inputs are you see what the output
should be for the things in the hidden
layer are not seen in the training set
so that kind of explains the name hidden
layer just means you don't see it in the
training set let's introduce a bit more
notation whereas previously we were
using the vector X to denote the input
features an alternative notation for the
values of the info features will be a
superscript square bracket 0 and the
term a also stands for activations and
it refers to the values that different
layers of the neural network are passing
on to the subsequent layers so the input
layer passes on the value X to the
hidden layer so we're going to call that
code the activations of the info layer
in superscript 0 the next layer the
hidden layer will in turn generate some
set of activations which I'm going to
write as a superscript square bracket 1
so particular this first
units or this first node will generate a
value a superscript square bracket 1
subscript 1 this second node we generate
the value now with a subscript 2 and so
on and so a superscript square bracket 1
this is a four dimensional vector or if
you want in Python occurs this period or
by one matrix or four column vector
which looks like this and it's four
dimensional because in this case we have
four nodes or four units or four hidden
units in this hidden layer then finally
the output layer will generate some
value a two which is just a real number
and so Y hat is going to take on the
value of a 2 so this is analogous to how
in logistic regression we have Y hat
equals a and prolific regression which
we only had that one output layer so we
didn't use the superscript square
brackets but within your network we're
now going to use this superscript square
bracket to explicitly indicate which
layer it came from one funny thing about
notational conventions in your networks
is that this network that you're seeing
here is called a two layer on your
network and the reason is that when we
come layers in your networks we don't
count the input layer so the hidden
layer is layer 1 and your output layer
is layer to another notational
convention we're calling the input layer
layer 0 so technically maybe there are
three layers in this view Network
because the input layer in the hidden
layer and the open layer but in
conventional users if you research
papers m and L so in the course
you see people refer to this particular
neural network as a two layer neural
network because we don't count the input
layer as a as an official layer finally
something that we'll get to later is
that the hidden layer and the output
layers will have parameters associated
with it so the hidden layer will have
associated with their parameters W and B
and going to write superscript square
bracket 1 to indicate that these are
parameters associated with layer 1 with
a hidden layer we'll see later that W
will be a or by 3 matrix and B will be a
4 by 1 vector in this example where the
first coordinate 4 comes in the fact
we have four nodes or four hidden units
and lair and three comes from the fact
that we have three input features we'll
talk later about the dimensions of these
matrices and it might make more sense at
that time but in similarly the open
layer as associated with it also
parameters W superscript square bracket
2 and B superscript square bracket 2 and
it turns out the dimensions of these are
one by four and one by one and this one
by fours because the hidden there has
four hidden units the output layer has
just one unit on bergame we'll go over
the dimensions of these matrices and
vectors in a data video so you've just
seen what a two layer neural network
looks like that is a neural network with
one hidden layer in the next video let's
go deeper into exactly what this new
network is computing that is how this
neural network
inputs X and goes all the way to
computing this output Y hat